I reckon we are live with another
YouTube hang out strategy fantasy sesh
number 14 with Jennifer price the
fantasy copywriter Jen welcome back
thank you it's good to be here thanks
for having me I like your new background
it's super cool yeah I guess since the
last one we did that now there's a new
background have i told you the thing
with the nenas story here you heard that
one yet I don't think I've heard that
yet okey so this is my background the
ideas when I walk in i'm inspired and
they don't know these people looking at
me and everybody has their own kind of
story as to why they're up there right
right this nina and hayden so my
computer setup like this and then i have
a spot right here where i usually keep
their picture okay so that while I'm
working like I don't see these guys
while I'm working right yeah it's you
know I'm Hayden while I'm working us
it's worth usual spot is but Nina gets
upset that her picture is not in the
shot when I doing hangouts so I have to
adjust so that your hangouts it goes
here and then I love it there so that's
awesome so do you move it back so that
when you because when you're working you
want to be able to see them right Zach
no I'm on the back but then like 30
things not to move it here just so that
we do the hay and also when I do the do
a morning a YouTube thing with with
marisha with Russia kept TV playing
league of legends and so I have to move
it back in for that so constantly on the
move between the two spots that's
awesome I did not know you did that with
reishi I did not know you did league of
legends with her are you kidding me yeah
one wednesday and friday morning we do a
stream and we answer questions while I
play league of legends oh my god that's
awesome does she play too or initiate
she just on the call with you oh yeah
she doesn't play she he moderates the
stream and then she asks the questions
and it also answers some of the
questions so okay yeah that's fun it's
good there's a test it's a new test I
like experimenting yeah he had me to uh
so it's been a while may was our last
our last call number 13 yeah what's that
what's the quick update what's been
um let's see well since may I have
continued doing some workshops i think i
did my first workshop last time we
talked so i've done two more since then
and i've had like a four hundred percent
increase in my tenants because i think
the first one i only had one person calm
which was which was totally great right
that's we gotta start somewhere and she
hired me so that was great and then I
had two more and they've had four people
at each of those and so that's been
great and I know one of the suggestions
you made was to introduce at those
workshops how people could continue to
work with me and so I have done that and
that's been really great too and I've
also offered to help them continue
writing their pages because what I'm
doing is I'm helping them are either
write in about page or sales page and so
that's been working out great too it's
been a great reason to follow up with
them and then help them out and show
them what I do in my skills and that
kind of thing cool any of the other ones
led to sales they haven't led the sales
yet but they but the other thing i've
done is i've sent feedback to them I you
know be a survey to get feedback from
them and and at both of the most recent
ones they suggested that they really
felt like when one workshop wasn't
enough that they you know they got late
later realize how intense it was right
and that they would love to be able to
do more so I am I so I'm and that's the
whole goal right to show them how much
work that goes into writing it but I
think a lot of do you want to write on
their own so i think i may consider
doing some kind of a series or a
two-part thing um you know I'm thinking
about that because that is definitely a
feedback that I got this is a free
workshop right you're putting on it's
not free um I offer it it's super cheap
I offer it for 40 bucks per person and
then after a discount to people who are
in my networking groups so what he bucks
for how long an hour or two hours Wow is
40 books to two hours okay what about um
and then the in May you were talking
about work chest with connectors are you
how are you promoting these workshops
well right now I'm promoting them
primarily through I have three different
networking groups that I belong to and
so I'm putting that i created a little
mini sales page for them and i put it up
on there
our Facebook pages and then I've also
been just putting it out on people that
I know who I think might be might want
to come I've considered like putting it
into into my mailing list or maybe on my
you know much Facebook page the problem
is is my you know their local workshops
and some I much facebook page actually
is primarily most people on that are
actually outside of the Portland area so
yeah yeah so I'm actually considered
that's one of things I was thinking
about doing actually I was so I think
you saw my mouth my group how bummed i
was about blab going away what if one of
the things I was thinking about doing
was doing a little mini workshops once a
week on blab just so anyone and everyone
could kind of get benefit from that and
kind of for free maybe not quite as
intense as I do in these to our
workshops because there wouldn't be
enough time to really get into it but
you know a good way to kind of introduce
the subject and let them know what I do
um but unfortunately Bob's going away so
I'm considering what might be to replace
that I might do it on youtube live or I
don't know i'm not i might see what blog
can i do to you will see how the whole
YouTube thing shakes out too because
they're getting rid of that and so we'll
see because i use hang us all the time
so we'll see what that ends up becoming
how to bring people in yeah i'm i think
your best bet I mean what you're looking
at it mean it's great that you're making
some a little bit of money at least now
so you got like you know 40 bucks times
for people you know make your time there
for the night um just covers my cost
because I have to pay for a room and now
snacks I mean it's basically for free
you know but right yeah I like playing
in either the free or the high value
right now we're like I getting paid a
lot and you use the free to filter out
the people who want to go to the next
step yeah so you is basically free right
because you're not making money um I
think it's much point about trying to
get the right target audience to come in
all right so I don't want people who
want to become copywriters yes you have
some kind of coaching program or
training program where you can teach
them and earn more money doing that as
well so understanding the point of the
series because if you're getting
feedbacks and hey we want more like that
was really intense we want more uh like
you may not want to do more if that's
not your business model right I'm not
trying to attract writers you're trying
to talk business people who don't want
to write yep and maybe focus shouldn't
be explaining the course to do a part 2
or part 3 yes I totally great that's
exactly what my thought was to it was
like really it's really meant to show
them that it's intense so if they want
to continue not doing it on their own
they have I give them a lot of intense
materials so they can do it on their own
you're right like that's not probably
the private person I want to attract
most these people aren't necessarily
writers but they're just new or business
owners that might just want to pay for
you don't want to pay for a writer right
now because they can afford it or
whatever and so they're wanting to write
their own page one of the things I've
sort of you know encourage them to do is
to hire me as a consultant so that they
can still do the writing and make I
could give them feedback on their
writing and that way doesn't take as
much time for me to do the writing
itself but to consult with them on an
ongoing basis I think that might make
more sense because then they can afford
it and it also helps helps them
establish a brand a little better and
the messaging behind their brand over a
longer term and then it's worth it for
me if you know if someone was willing to
pay me it cooks consulting fee for a
couple hours a month you know for six
months that it's totally worth of me so
I think that's a better route than than
having it longer workshop series i
totally agree I would also see if
they're open to doing it as a live
coaching session like this public where
it's going to go to youtube because that
also benefits it benefits them and they
get some exposure if they're willing to
share you know what's going on but it
also helps you build content to try to
attract other people who want to get
advice on how to like it's it's still a
lot of free stuff that a lot of people
will come and we'll just consume and
hopefully help them with their business
and if you're in a little bit ad dollars
off of it but helps become a funnel for
people again who look at that and say
wow that's a ton of work I don't want to
do that can I just hire Jen to help me
yeah I love that idea that's actually
kind of what I was thinking about with
the blob thing so maybe yeah maybe it's
just some one on one thing and
said yeah I'll think about that that's
that's a great idea and then I wouldn't
have to pay for the room fee either so I
could actually even offshore lot less
money right so yeah if you're getting if
you're getting paid for two you're gonna
pay for your time how a position is is
good for them it's good for their
business you can also start getting some
feedback from people watching and
getting their opinions and their advice
interviews and you can you can rally
your community around saying hey you
know this thursday i'm doing a session
with jill and we're going to talk about
her business come and give feedback and
so the way i always approach it as I
don't I don't ask for permission on it
like hey would you mind if I did this
thing because then it makes it look like
it's a favor to you right our position
is as where it still is it is good for
you but imagine as it's been good for
them and that I like to do it this way I
want to give you more exposure I want to
give you some live real-time feedback
and what you're doing both for myself
and from the live audience that will
bring even if like two people show up
it's still something back and it helps
them uh it helps them grow to as a as an
entrepreneur to be able to you know be
on camera in practice being vulnerable
and some people absolutely hate it and
won't want to do it but I'll surprise
you how many people who would we got
ache like I've never had anybody turn it
down anytime somebody wants to interview
me or for their podcast or for their if
it's a youtuber it's easy because you're
used to YouTube podcasters or people
read an article or somebody wants
mentorship I've always said let's just
do it as a google hangout and I'm gonna
happy I'm happy to promote you to my
audience and we'll get some live
feedback and they've always some of them
been really scared isn't my first time
going on camera oh my god I live yeah I
totally but you know they mean a little
bit of hand-holding through that process
like don't worry you'll be fine you know
we'll just walk through it you'll be
you'll be great so I've never had
anybody seen oh and that helps me build
up you know content for my channel too
but also helps give them exposure to to
the audience so yeah I whether it's free
or ideally it's a paid session I would
trying to make that into a live event so
you have content per channel 2 and even
if you're doing your workshops I'd love
it to be filmed right you have content
on channel um taking back to to the
strategies of workshops you know the
idea is we want to get ideal clients
coming in there and your ideal client is
it is a business owner as an
entrepreneur yeah it's an entrepreneur
who I mean probably the most ideal
client is somebody who's got you know a
couple of of employees and they're doing
and they need help because they're doing
some kind of a launch of some kind
whether it's like an online you know
course or they're doing something where
they need you know help write in a page
on their website about it to get sales
right so i would i would start looking
at who was already dealing with these
people like maybe it's not your
networking groups maybe maybe those
people are just solo entrepreneurs and
they love the idea but they can't afford
your services which is very real right
so lame go Phil pay 40 bucks for a
couple hours I mean be consulting gig
here there but it's not really the kind
of kind that you want to bring on build
your business around right well looking
at who is dealing with these kinds of
ideal clients and how can this be
something that they can do for their
clients um so as an example there is a
local SEO company here who built his
business by partnering up with business
coaches okay business coaches in the
area and they have enough budget to hire
business coach so it's not right now
like it might be a pure started but
stills pure start that has enough money
to hire business coach and they would do
a free workshop for all of the clients
of the business coach so the business
culture then go out and say hey you know
I've got this SEO expert come in and
talk about SEO for your company it's a
free event on me is my you know
appreciation for you guys as little
clients let's meet up at you know
whatever their office or some some
location and so he used that to hop
around to different business coaches and
it was value add for the business coach
to really provide that to their
clients as a free service so you know if
you can get into a room of 20 ideal
clients right who have the budget people
have a need is a good chance you're
going to land you know at least one sale
coming out of there so it's more about
finding those people who can be good
connectors for you yeah whether it's
business coaches or accountants or
lawyers or website design companies if
they're talk about landing pages and
need some coffee from SEO companies
anybody who's working with these
entrepreneurs I mean there's really some
within your networking group that you
can yeah um instead of just trying to
target the people in the group may be
targeting their the people that they
work with right Florian's for people
that they work with exactly and so if
you could do some of those if you can do
a couple those workshops a month you'll
quickly end up having a pretty full
stable of that's cool I like that idea
especially website developers are a
great target because they obviously work
with balloon you know they're working
doing website work for people so um even
people cuz a lot of times do they do all
our kind of project by project basis but
maybe I offer them some kind of
incentive for referring me to look for a
workshop yeah you you you could some
some people uh I think you want to
approach you to make sure that they know
it's not just gonna be a hard sales
pitch right you're not just going to go
in and try to sell their clients because
they're putting it as hey here's some
value add thank you for being my client
I'm bringing in gen to talk to us about
how to write better coffee for your
website and business yeah so I think if
people have the need don't actually want
to talk to you about it you can explain
the next steps some people are very
money oriented and then we'll want to
see some kind of thing back Commission
others honor term doing it because they
want to provide the value and that could
be off-putting like not i'm bringing you
in to provide value not to sell my
client right so you just want to you
know play that by ear um what's it
develops will be an interesting choice
yes there's a strategic fit ah you could
also be their competitor
pending on right the company mhm part of
their business they use copywriters
sometimes you do it in-house sometimes a
outsource um yeah I've found a lot of
them do outsourced but they do have
their prefer people but one of the
things i have noticed is a lot of them
like to not have the cooperator work
directly with a client almost like an
agency um which I don't really prefer I
don't really necessarily want to work
with those web developers because I
think it's so important that I work
directly with the client so I know
exactly you mean yeah they do kind of
they might consider me what a competitor
I wouldn't because I don't want to
design websites and I'll have you know I
would but form a threat to them of any
kind but I get sometimes they just for
control reasons they want to control the
situation so yeah it's it's more that
they you know you don't do all of their
services what you do one of theirs right
okay right they sell copy and you sell
copy that's a competitive situation you
may feel the work out a deal where you
like if talk to the client is important
obviously for you to get to know them
and create the best experience and best
result yeah you could also sign a like a
one-year yeah it's some sort of like
agreement that i won't contact them for
other projects yeah right and and or if
like anything that comes to anything
that comes has to go through them for
one year or whatever mm-hmm and i would
be a timeline on it but I'd be willing
to offer that up to the agencies because
at the end they they want to provide the
best well they should one probably the
best result to their client when that
works yeah and if you have a process on
how to get that and it needs to come
from talking to client directly I get
the fear I get the figure just going to
poach clients right you know the website
development business is highly
competitive and you know they want they
don't want you poach a client and then
even if it's only for the copy but then
it could be like oh you know what this
is other website guys who are really
good to you should go with them right
not big lost totally well they like the
control to I think I think it's more a
matter of and sometimes they'll up
charge it or or even if they don't
charge it they want to control the cost
for their client make it really low so
they have this like they might say okay
I'm developing a website for you and you
know this will include the copy and then
they want to like you know they want to
need a bit low because they want to keep
the under certain control costs which
doesn't make sense the client if it's
not going to get enough so yeah yeah and
a lot of vacancies don't respect the
subcontractors enough and I ain't want
you don't under it I mean I think the
pricing the the payment will still
likely go through the SEO company the
web company yeah you can be fine with
that say hey you guys invoice I'll
invoice you and then you book you push
them um there's a lot of companies that
start off that way doing those kinds of
partnerships and then just end up find
their own clients because it's a more
ideal situation yeah um so what you know
it really depends on the personality of
the people who own that business if they
see was value either if they just see
you as a you know piece of me you know
like they know the copywriter another
copywriter right right people really
value and some people don't so yeah I
agree um so it's one avenue worth
looking at but I'd also be looking at
who else it is selling to your ideal
client base business coaches accountants
lawyers anybody who's working with
entrepreneurs again like hyper local to
your area so you can go in and make a
presentation maybe film it if there's an
opportunity but really this is kind of
lead generation to help you get some
ideal clients for yourself yeah I also
plan to sort of leverage it I mean I
think I like video filming it just if
nothing else for the effect for myself
but I also you know really do you want
to develop an online course of some kind
and so my thinking you know was I can
this is kind of repurpose material that
I can use to develop an online course
for other people it's that i can sell
online then so it's not even just
workshop but that it provides another
source of revenue for me sure i would
look at i would look at that especially
doing the twenty-dollar one or the forty
dollar ones or if you're going to do
some free ones you can use some coaching
or consulting and do those into live
hangout sessions uh it's a possibility
of doing it when you're working with
like if you work with the business
coaching he's bringing 20 of his clients
and my focus would be on giving
those 20 people in same value and not
necessarily worrying about videotaping
it yeah I totally hurt that Yeah right
cuz that you know you get one great
client of that that's yeah that's a good
meal ticket for the next you know track
of time yeah um so I'll be looking at
you know like type in portland business
coach and see who's coming up and maybe
even help them like give them a couple
ideas for their website of what they
think might be able to do how they
explain themselves so it kind of
demonstrates your value of what you can
provide um yeah that's it's hard because
a lot of entrepreneurs like the ideal
clients are you looking for they don't
go to networking events right for the
most part you know it's herding cats
like they're too busy running their
business you also the people go to
networking events are super early stage
or haven't haven't started yet and so
it's really hard to get any kind of
ideal client out of that there are other
groups to like there's tak the
entrepreneurs the entrepreneur community
tech waipio i don't know how many of
them are based in what you're at these
guys have bigger like multi-million
dollar businesses right I think waipio
was eight or ten million dollars minimum
revenue but so I mean they have the
budget to be able to afford right help
them with our country it's worth looking
into the different groups and
organizations and like I would I would
just spend a half a day doing research
on everybody in Portland who's
connecting with entrepreneurs and then
figure out how you can get on their
radar and do a free event for their
clients try to line up three or four or
five of those and if you've already done
it a couple times you got like the flow
what you're going to say and what
resonates and um then I think that's
what I want everybody walking out
feeling like it was a lot of value there
and you're naturally going to get people
who want to come and work with you yeah
yeah no I know exact what you're saying
that's part of why i was doing these pro
shops you just kind of get practice for
other events another reason is obviously
to repurpose that material that's I mean
that is one of the challenges for me as
a as a business owner and I'm sure you
can relate you know or come across other
people who understand this is you know
like I think people really want to work
with people they know like a trois tribe
that they know you I do a lot better
obviously if I'm face to face with
somebody but like you said a lot of my
and that's one of the reasons why i
started going to networking events but a
lot of the a lot because a lot of the
people who really are my target are
really online they're online
entrepreneurs who are launching courses
or launching products online and selling
things online and so reaching those
people with a cold you know cold call or
email isn't always super effective
because they don't really know you know
they don't know me from Adam so it's
just going it's getting into into those
networks and so I like your idea of
looking at other organizations because
maybe there's other groups both online
and here locally that have more of those
kinds of entrepreneurs as members yeah
and and like every entrepreneur is a
website every entrepreneur needs mm-hmm
copy for their website for their store
for the product descriptions for their
resume you know like if they're going
out and speaking they may need to update
their bio like there's a lot of
different things that people could use
entrepreneur needs copy in their
business um it's probably the fastest
way to get you like as much as I love
YouTube and all of that it's probably
the fastest way to get you a stable of
clients that are in the bills and
helping you might give you some
breathing room YouTube is people who are
searching for it and you know hoping
that one of them becomes right the
client most people will never pay for
anything or everyone to contact you
right all right that's just the nature
of the game but here you have people who
are I think it's a much longer term play
like YouTube is a longer term play and
allows you to build up an audience and
Lau's you to make much bigger moves
mm-hmm want to sell courses the need an
audience who will sell it to that you'll
do much better at with an online
strategy then with a going to event
there's 10 to 20 people at and Trent
then trying to sell your dirty dollar
course or whatever just the numbers
don't add up mm-hmm but in the short run
like in the the trading time for money
kind of business that's that's
like--that's what i would spend most of
my effort yeah those introductions and
trying to do those free seminars to
build some connections and build some
build some business going it's exciting
like squiddy you've done a couple now
swimming those into let's start talking
exactly yeah no I agree i think you're
right a lot into visible over longer
term play which I just wanted still
committed to it because I think it's a
great way to communicate what I do also
and then you know I think I just need to
that's one thing I've given it to doing
is you know leveraging that a little bit
more I've been making these YouTube
videos and then not you know I've been
posting my twitter but not post them on
my youtube channel or I haven't but or
not I'm not YouTube not you posting them
on my Facebook page and then I haven't
been really promoting it you know in
everywhere that I can so haven't been
sending emails out so things like that
so i think i'm gonna start i'll
definitely get started setting them up
by email at least my copywriting ones
that idea once a week and then I'm gonna
start promoting like with a little mini
trailer videos on Facebook and snapchat
I just start recently got a snapchat a
love addict by the way my 14 year old
daughter's I'll have to show me how to
use it and I still was so confused
because it's it's kind of confusing but
anyway it's a great it's a great fun fun
platform to so anyway just things like
that so that I can really I mean I'm
committed to doing it so might as well
keep promoting it and try and build my
audience more there so yeah I think I
think as well just by keeping doing it
you focus on the content keep getting
the content better right like somebody
watch your video and want to instantly
share it to their audience uh you know
that's it that's a constant struggle for
me I think I probably go through this
once a quarter where I look at my
channel look at my videos like ah I
should be I should have more views and
should have more subscribers than I'm at
now and you know sure I have you know
quarter without subscribers or whatever
but it still feels like it's the quality
of stuff I'm I know and I mean
no it's a lot but it's still not a lot
in the YouTube world right I feel like
with the stuff I'm putting out and the
amount of effort hard work like why is
it so low convert to where I think it
should be and about once a quarter I go
through that we're like I kind of market
at market how can I market this more you
know what you should I talk to her how
can I pump this out more on my Twitter
newsletter email list or whatever um and
at the end of the day always comes down
to just make better stuff right right
box because that's work uh and so you
know doing that doing the quantity helps
you get to the quality like keep doing
it every week the consistency your video
is now are better than they were when
they started you know rii videos better
than the last um and so like there is no
magic bullet yes like absolutely put it
out to the newsletter put it on facebook
it'll drive a couple more views um but
the real thing is going to be making the
videos better owning the message better
when I watch it I want to instantly
apply what you what you said or sure
what the friends going through something
similar and that's a that's a high bar
yea high even for me for my videos is a
high bar people watch the video and even
if they like it they don't share it
mm-hmm so I've got to get better right
I've got it Mike Witt is better um yeah
I mean I that is definitely one thing I
that was my first focus is making it
better which I feel like there will wait
like you said the way better than they
were even like even four months ago I
just like the contents that are the
headlines are better you know there's a
lot there's a lot of improvement but
you're right i mean I could you know I
can still make it better right you can
always make it better and I don't you
know make it more intriguing for people
to keep watching more and more so I know
you've got I mean you're insane how many
videos you put Alex I don't know how you
do it like that yeah i mean i do well on
the team right touches me yeah right
there's six of us who just do youtube uh
and it's it's also you know we could
pump out what we could do 20 videos a
day if you wanted to but then the
quality would suffer right this is low
that we can put out with the quality
that I want at the moment yeah um so but
but like my channel grew as I became
more consistent as I started posting
more regularly you can see the spike
with fans and subscribers as well um
yeah it's helping me too i'm at 95 i'm
almost at 100 yeah yeah i love it it's
coming it's right around the corner
right on fire I'll be able to celebrate
cool well well I still think like the
most important thing if you can get
those workshops with those connectors
focus on that for the next month ah you
know I don't know what your look time
looks like today but sit down and make a
list of all the business coaches in
Portland and yeah I love it reach out to
this actually what I do in my networking
group said anything about like you know
them specifically so that's a great idea
I mean also it's a definitely great
place to start i would i would just
question again a lot of people go to
network into groups are not successful
yet and so they may not have the base
that you're looking for for ideal
clients yeah so it's not about place to
start it's not a bad place to get a
little more experience I just look at
the room when you come in like are these
the people that you want to eventually
sell stuff to or not and that mean it
may mean looking outside your current
group to other you know more successful
coaches who aren't going to networking
groups but just make an introduction and
saying this is what you want to do we're
grabbing coffee or having a quick phone
call you can write it you know you can
write a great email your you do copy so
um so I'm so here go and I agree for it
yeah totally cool awesome thank you so
much Evan well I have a great month will
connect with you soon good luck into
those hundreds of subscribers and next
time we'll talk i'll be at a hundred yes
yes and have done a couple seminars to
yep absolutely alright thanks Jen thank
you that tech 11 cheers